rien ne semble pouvoir perturber le
calme de ce village même pas l'annoncé
mercredi dernier du rachat par un
américain du domaine bono du martray
l'un des plus prestigieux domaine
bourguignon masquer la maj déjà c'est
que notre patrimoine part je suis un peu
dommage pour le pour la france et pour
le pays en même temps pour la bourgogne
je pense que bon on m'a souvent dit
s'est vendu il ya des américains qui
achètent en france mais aussi des
français qui achètent aux états unis je
pense que la maison droit on est un bon
exemple
donc il faut savoir échanger et pourquoi
pas le domaine bono du martray ce sont
onze hectares de vignes d'un seul tenant
ayant la particularité de ne compter que
des grands crus du corps ton et du
corton charlemagne depuis deux siècles
ce domaine appartient à la famille le
bault de la morinière elle faute
d'héritiers repreneur les propriétaires
ont contacté une dizaine d'acheteurs
potentiels à travers le monde et c'est
stanley crunk qui l'emportait pour une
somme qui pourrait atteindre les 200
millions d'euros
ce milliardaire américain de 69 ans est
propriétaire de nombreux clubs sportifs
dans l'équipe de foot anglaise d'arsenal
il possède également plusieurs domaines
viticoles en californie le 20 une
véritable passion pour ce nabab
de quoi rassurer les viticulteurs
bourguignons quand des gens investissent
dans un domaine parce que ils ont une
passion pour le vannes je pense que
c'est plutôt favorable à la bourgogne
même si effectivement on peut toujours
regretter que ça soit pas des
viticulteurs cachette mais dans les prix
qu'ils sont
donné on peut difficilement voir que des
investisseurs extérieurs avec des
grosses fortunes pour pouvoir se
permettre d'investir
quel que soit le montant de la
transaction on sait que la société de
monsieur crunk ne détiendra pas
l'intégralité du capital du domaine la
famille baud de la morinière conservera
20 % des parts